[Music]
zoom in just gonna say it I gotta let
you go you for just 5 oz let go for
liability reasons involves an insurance
but one-armed boss and I'm on your solo
expect Charlotte Motor Speedway I'm them
how they move the money
[Music]
the only God knows anything about
blowing up real bank boxes Joe bang em
in car sir ready and you know we gotta
play on the kitchen well coca-cola 600
is the biggest race of the year we need
a computer with I know that fingers know
about computers okay
all the Twitter's I know welcome to the
coca-cola 600
how many thoughts away use of all twenty
yards all right 30 is it 20 or is it 30
we are dealing with science here they're
gonna know what we want them to know my
life of crime is over
[Music]
that is massively stupid if it handled
all this into because that looks like it
hurt
I want everything under Gilligan I'm
about get naked to Kuwait
I said no bacon
[Applause]
you moving must be a simple mad as
people say they will say that what
you're giving my arm please and it is
this one this is the United States Drug
Enforcement Agency we are ordering you
to land hi boys let's land
my name is Barry seal that's for the
damage for your sister hey little
darling and you're back somebody's [ __ ]
really happened you never saw me out of
your class in Civil Air Patrol pilot
like you shouldn't be flying busted
welcome I am
welcome to Bakersfield haven't you ever
wanted something more Barry you should
be serving your country you're CIA
we need you to deliver stuff for us all
this is legal if you're doing it for the
good guys
Barry seal their goddamn genius you are
an airline pilot Barry that's how you
support this family is it going to be
good for us how legal
trust me oh we're expanding operations
Barry no no the TT
[Music]
Roscoe dug this up in the backyard there
bill blowing around everywhere I'll rake
it up in the morning gun does money
laughing you don't know it caddies have
more trunk space than any other car I
get each and every one of you caddy your
troubles I'm going to walk out of here
too
I read a damn thing any wonder you can
do about it hey wait should have taken a
cash
I was working for the CIA a DEA and
Pablo Escobar minions of kilos that's 15
like the under kilos are in one go get
it done we needed a miracle and then we
got one this beautiful and special
little creature will be our revolution
in the livestock industry our super pigs
will not only be big and beautiful they
will all believe a minimal footprint on
the environment consume less bees and
produce less excretion and most
importantly they need to taste [ __ ]
good
[Music]
[Music]
we are animal lovers our plan is to
expose Miranda rescues poke Joe and
bring her back to you the ten years been
planning on the comes with a product
that will feed millions for what happens
that's armored growth is going to
destroy us should know the situation is
now before you
[Music]
Eshan we have to tell all those little
white lies
gentlemen what God together
for the one the only
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
this is Michael Bryce
secular protection agent I've extracted
my client clean up is required might
want to call the bomb squad
make it the fire department come on Co
I'm afraid come have a seat get along
the trial continues one of the wolf
books rebuilding night where they keep
witness to testify I can assure you
we're more than fact running so
therefore that assault [ __ ] and
Kincaid is dead you'll be paid if they
have no property I have a job
the temple is in there
what 27 times
that's how many times this [ __ ]
tried to kill me 26 28 you will last one
hour without me don't be a little [ __ ]
about where your husband is
you lost my husband that is your job
[Applause]
if you wouldn't mind the gun
you
yo you pop down
okay hunt 3-1 my bad your bad know what
life gives you [ __ ] you make go away
life doesn't usually give you [ __ ] and
then turn into a beverage look who just
the music Maddy McCallister what should
I say
just play it cool welcome to the world
inside your phone where everyone is
expected to act one way their whole life
how lamenting and I'm supposed to be a
man you know it's massacred my problem
is I have more than one emotion sex
itself huh
please tell me you weren't laughing just
now what if you get sent out on the
phone making the wrong face and I'll
make the right face then I will finally
fit in
created you're so handsome and you make
that face I think he's ready now man SAP
our user Alex we have an incoming text
we are go for men looting me la keeps
making the wrong face huh what the heck
welcome to the loser lounge where the
emojis you never get used hangout what's
up laughs are I'm an emoji a God has
done sort of perfect here I'm gonna help
you
we need to get off the phone and find
the source code then I can fit in let's
roll my Felicia
first you have to get to this firewall
we go up this girlfriend's name again it
was Tina
Karen Sarah I want to say Lupita
but that doesn't feel right now I'm
saying out loud I think you're pretty
cool just the way you are
[Music]
the phone my feelings are huge
maybe I meant have more than just one
emotion where life can be crush divine
oh never in another piece of candy ever
again huh high-five don't do it don't
you do it it's already been in there
once okay son what do we do after we go
potty should we wash our hands
[Music]
every civilization
was built off the back of a disposable
workforce but I can only make so many
happy birthday there is an order to
things
that's what we do here we keep order
[Music]
the world is built on a wall that
separates kind
now either side there's no wall
you bought a war
[Music]
your cop
amateur job once sounds good
I know what do you want I want to ask
you some questions
the key to the future
it's finally on earth
for your time
you know you're here
[Music]
how it told you you're special your
story isn't over yet
first your page left
you
oh yes child I don't know but she was
you
she has no one else we are not savages
eggs fight only to survival
bad human kill 800 all dead man a long
time sometime bad humans its order
[Music]
here's from now your children will ask
you what did you do in the greatest war
and you can tell them I fought to
protect this world with creativeness but
now
[Music]
we will bring it in to their car
no mercy no peace this this warm had
dates together straight
who are impressive smart as hell
is stronger than we are that you're
taking this all much too personally
going off you know
I did not start this warm
what I will finish it
[Music]
[Music]
what has happened to colossal military
disaster
[Music]
we shall go on to the end we shall never
surrender the call went out we have to
go to Dunkirk ready on the stern line
we're doing sure where we're going into
war George I'll be useful sir about
economy
I'm on em
just about to leave
then these and more [ __ ] everywhere in
Wisconsin
to that crater the civilian does digit
we need to split
so we're going Dunkirk
I'm not real little diet your weekend
sale another bloody Navy should be at
home
he's no hiding from this Sun we have a
job to do
- beaches suffice from the landing
ground which we never surrender
what you could bloody Airport
[Music]
we were once mankind we were humanity
they came here to exterminate us will
die if we stay here baccala you can take
it out even until everyone about this
place
our government is unit I trust there's a
big algorithm what they can't explain
I'm with us they have built a
conservatory
so it's coming to my office to adapt to
die
[Music]
you know there is something about that
tangle of strangers pressed together for
days with nothing in common but they
need to go from one place to another and
never see each other again I see evil on
this train
a passenger has died so I got him after
all
you last seen was killed no no no no not
oh it wasn't perfectly good healthy it
had his enemies indeed he was another
God murder here God rest his soul
someone was rummaging around my cabin in
the middle of the night no one would
listen to me
if there was a murder what is going on
and there was a murderer the murderer is
with us and every one of you is a
suspect and who are you my name is RQ
Powell and I'm probably the greatest
detective in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
okay before we go we got to do human
friends but yeah
what is a human friend paid if the photo
we always take that's like the movie
Human Centipede where they're sewn
together mouth to anus but it's with
friends so it's special I in the middle
oh why do you want the milk this is it
your bachelorette weekend we have been
dreaming about this moment it's the
first day of freshman year we're going
to be swimming in big girl I just got a
call from The busboy why so everyone
that doesn't know I was kind of hoping
that we could make it an early meet this
doesn't feel right yeah I don't think so
baby girl honey [ __ ] fashion my god
I'm so hot baby God you so now you got
too much makeup not candy for your face
let's get a stripper male or female
though ma'am I think the mail for her
fine I can feel special
[Music]
oh god no no no no come on do I know you
get the picture zone which ones are
totally [ __ ] take my picture there was
this guy in Australia who cooked his
girlfriend and ate her
no I can't because I am vegan bar we can
helping the best weekend of our parking
lot I probably had HPV now whenever we
all have each TV I don't have HTV if
you've had sex after the in 1991 then
you do have HPV oh then I have like a
[ __ ] ton of HPV quantum Ponce of it okay
[Music]
remember homies play together
I got lost at work summer when I turned
around
[Music]
I'm sure you want it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Teresa
[Music]
Theresa
do you ever regret
cutting everything
you can't even [ __ ] away
[Music]
what did you do to reason what did you
do I'm Alice yeah Oh Alice please stop
avoiding me
look at me for a second Alice is merely
separated losers oh okay I'm not you
haven't I've got this thing about you
and it's super-president to be handling
everything really well Alice doesn't
know what she wants
you got to check yourself everything's
gonna be okay what are you going to tell
me that three strangers were living in
yet
I just always back down on my birthday
just like my own personal near zero I
just really think just reel it back to
normal
did you wash these I did but only
because I was doing a load and I've been
asleep by 30 like the ball park
I am not involved with her okay just
love a lot of things about like a faint
personality
[Applause]
amazing.you it state that they met you
[Music]
come on the pain
[Music]
I'm going to be
later
[Music]
I
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the city of a thousand planet after
century peace and prosperity an unknown
force ought to destroy all we have
created
Agence tellurian and laura-leigh and you
have less than ten hours to find the
threat
and eliminated
[Music]
history is on the March
[Music]
and your kids think that you'll always
be protected careful
you like kings Thanks should think is
too much hanging out with us makes me a
loser too but when you're alone as a kid
the master see you is weaker
[Applause]
you don't even know they're getting
closer until it's too late
what working for the night II know we're
okay well I'm starting it cheap and I'm
pretty sure this is not my damn bathroom
where's your mother
sometimes yes then you probably have
crab it's still not funny
I'll Cheetos coming in ah
greywater what the hell is gray one
basically piss and [ __ ] tom is telling
you you had to splash around millions of
gallons of dairy pee
so we are you seriously doesn't smell
like a consolation you I've been kind of
a staff and factoring all sorts of that
mesh so unsanitary it releases a little
something inside of a toilet bowl right
now here the reason why we're in this
position my gosh
sneaker is it spread eruptions what if
she's still here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
next your incredible to understand I'm
serious you think I got a dollar when I
do spend an extra you swore you throwing
this because I'm to win oh yeah oh yeah
look at knitting in there just keep your
head now turn around
[Music]
[Music]
so I told you about my brother yet
something happened I don't know exactly
what just an arrest is being held at
Rikers Island oh my god that's awesome
just got to get him out of there before
something bad happens
we get killed in this
damn
another tan grant you get another 10
grand you bowled it out
[Music]
I think something very important was
happening and deeply connected to my
purpose every day I think about um
twisting them to unity these streams I'm
in to lead a Pure Life
look at and clear sky ain't gonna get
there it's a nice dream
it's a nice tree
[Music]
I can emergency surgery to perform in
Baltimore I'll fly wherever I happen
tonight to get there tomorrow morning
can you help me sir
I think we may have a same problem I
have an idea so what's rush I'm getting
married tomorrow
Oh congratulations no no it's we're not
we just left
what's the key Idaho medical conference
regarding it I would explain the
questions
[Music]
anyway
Alex look at me you really hurt your leg
phone smashed my phone has no signal and
we're pretty high up on the mountain we
stay here we're safe if we leave her to
rescue they're less likely to find us
look I want to die up here because
you're too scared to take a risk
someone's over force pilot in Firefly
planet
nobody knows where we are we're all we
got me and you
we can go three weeks without booth
three days without water and three hours
without shelter
we might die together I don't even know
you
[Music]
no good a diet
good today
right
[Music]
I need emergency assistance
watch the Wind River Indian Reservation
I'm June banner okay
welcome to Wyoming by yourself good
thing that's Cory clambered he's where I
found the body
there's a homicide I knew that girl
she's a fighter
because six officers to cover an area
the size of Rhode Island maybe you can
help only know its track site what is it
you do again I'm thirsty so why don't
you come hunt one for me then
why would a teenage girl be out here
what's he running from here the
seclusion where you're missing all the
signs
shouldn't we wait for backup this isn't
lend the backup James this is a land of
you're on your own
oh my god
you won't get the answers you're looking
for matter which defined
while your daughter run some homes to
play my wife did tell me you you cannot
bring Debra - please
what it takes musk I took from you the
key luck is in the city
what don't let out here
[Music]
five some funky on there just the case
we got a riff to show it up so here's
the thing I'm looking with some of the
country's finest thugs and of course
young Mozart in a go-kart over there
[Applause]
people love great thanks robbery story
so let's give them something full and
brazenness to talk about over there not
what you listening
Akilah this it is bananas de aquila
aren't you the lucky one that's right
you tell them baby
[Music]
och you sit right there
[Music]
[Applause]
damn right
I'm sorry ma'am finally here we go
good evening here oh you have 500 only 6
possible elimination
I can keep that too yeah fun for me
where's Ernie look tree next mission
will call you all right
that's not a hug him just grab the top
we're all right there yet
all right kid good luck out there
Figg yeutter you going tonight I can't
tonight I got the start internship
what's up guys here's my report for
tonight I stopped the grandstand flights
go hey could you do me a favor hold on
that
here's anybody's bye oh I helped us the
old lady and she bought me a churro so I
was nice I just promised I could be
doing more wait a minute you guys on the
real event just hope gives it away
new move them working on the bed he's
weapons are crazy dangerous mr. Taylor
they're people who handle the sword
can't it just be a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys timely change
to my can't prove my top will use
Spanish Queen you gotta get better at
this part of the job Oh imma dated
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting hungry bye
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocols because mister
stop treating me like a kid but you are
a kid you can stop a boss with his bare
hands
you
[Music]
thousand years we've kept it hidden the
secret history of transformers
[Music]
[Music]
shortly after you and your brother were
born
your father and I divorced and we each
took one son obviously ha ha ha I got
second pick I have a twin brother my
brother fine maybe you practice
companies al-arian so how are things
career-wise ha ha great you let the most
wanted villains just get away you're
fired
those are great crashing it brought you
here to continue the family business
believe in your blood and broken food
and left that life behind me I
understand hmm I wonder what this does
oh holy moly common villain the game
what did you guys do today there's
always a blind guy
[Music]
[Music]
what about that school Wow oh girl I'll
make you learn to appreciate me
differently Jamie we've been waiting a
long time
it was so fluffy I thought I was from a
day me on the Thomas before you defeat
me no you two are villains now
I mean hello speedy are you getting all
the kissing guys please
I'm a weapon of Mao's discussion come on
buddy
this is going to be a stealth mission
don't tell me you're scared
there's nothing safer than a dark alley
ah just a lovable little dolly okay
that's a little creepy
dang this is bad it's been nice knowing
your buddy
you scared us you little guy Boop some
call me kills Oh got it
my name is mr. Fang I was cursed with
this big adorable eyes and this fuzzy
little buddy why are you here I need
your help to take back the park this
part has everything we need the mayor
wants to destroy everything I got bigger
plants and trees and power they're going
to destroy the park that's let's go
don't you see we're all animals we need
to look out for each other
we are in this together if we want to
stop the Mariners going it squirrel sees
it's gonna pick everyone what should we
do try to not get killed I'll try but I
can't make any promises
individually we might be tiny but
together with giant doing all over I
don't know how I'm not classically
trained don't get a boys
I'm the weapon of mouth discussion
drinking little rodents if they stop me
wow this is gonna be fun
now
[Music]
meet my new friend mr. Fang that reminds
me
don't go cannonball you'll excuse me I
got to get back to slacking off precious
we talked about it's hard to respect
your personal space when it tastes like
peanut butter look at all of you lady is
toiled in fact take it easy Andy it's
not like the nut shops gonna explode oh
no the peanut butter was in there I'll
find a new place even better than the
nut shop as pretty as a picture perfect
Liberty Park generate zero profit I got
bigger plants and trees and amusement
park they're gonna destroy the park the
fat guy with a dining shovel how much
damage can he do
oh I get it tiny shovel with a symbolic
gesture this park is worth fighting for
I got this let's see you drive down
I'm good but you guys get the next one
my crazy plans don't work they'll follow
you anywhere surly you can do it it's
all you know it's not all day if you
want to stop these guys it's gonna take
everything back let's go get off what
are you doing well over I don't know how
I'm not classically trained
what's that mole you like it the very
existence of this game offends me we
were overrun by enemies mangy little
rodents don't get up boys remember your
training
got to be a safety violation
[Music]
sorry
you